vous voyez qu'on arrive quand même à
vous faire part des notes il faut juste
un petit peu
plus timide sandrine kiberlain
n'arrive pas à passer par les doutes son
film alors comme elle en a pris
j'indique da cieux non c'est un film que
j'ai vraiment aimé faire parce qu'on est
cet acteur dedans et c'est super sonne
enfin les autres que j'aime beaucoup on
connaissait on se connaissait déjà avant
et moi si je peux parler du rôle d'
irène c'était
très intéressant à faire parce que c'est
une fille qui est très déprimée et
l'intérêt c'était delà de la rendre
patiente quoi c'est quand on est déprimé
en est souvent un chien et moi je
voulais avant de l'humour dans le temps
la dcri avait une déprime
cinématographiques les plus rudes drôle
qu'on ait vues depuis longtemps mais
j'en ai forcément drôle sinon on se fout
une balle dans la tête non mais c'est
comme quand j'ai bien aimé qu'elle
voulait pas parler au début
c'est toujours
moi même pour moi les grands optimistes
un des grands pessimistes et les plus
grands optimistes quoi sinon ils sont
c'est souvent les situations qui sont
les plus drôles je trouve ce sont les
situations qui viennent malgré nous quoi
kiki qui font rire malgré nous et cette
fille est très déprimée c'est elle est
drôle malgré l quoi il ya elle maîtrise
plus ses émotions aussi bien les larmes
que les rires que et elle est pleine de
calmants et ça l'a fait passer d'un état
à un autre comme ça sont calmées tri
spécialement ce qu'elle va faire et mes
skis a été formidable c'est le travail
avec pascal et avec les attentions qui a
eu une écoute entre les comédiens et
tout ça ça a été lâchement bien frédéric
pierrot c'était pas trop perturbant
d'être entouré comme ça de ces jeunes
non mais là on voyait des seuls au
milieu d'elle mais j'étais pas ça il y
avait deux autres mecs avec moi qui
étais marc citti et alain fromager non
non c'était pas flippant du tout non
à quoi vous avez été sensible vous dans
cette volonté de réconcilier les hommes
et les femmes qui sera un peu l'emblème
comme moi je vais pas penser à ça quand
on va tourner jeu parce que je savais
pas qu'elle pensait non j'ai juste pensé
que c'était un personnage c'est pas un
personnage extraordinaire pour ce qui
nous concerne c'est un type
ordinaire comme on en rencontre beaucoup
c'est par stallone jeudi au peuple par
rapport à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
voilà et c'est un moment d ordre dans la
vie de ces gens là
qui va s'ordonner pendant le film est ce
qu elle a fait comme travail etc et qui
est pas si simple que ça ça a l'air
facile quand on voit maintenant mais
c'est qu'elle a pris ce moment désordre
exactement comme quelqu'un de presque
scientifique irait chercher voir comment
chaque petite chose se passe entre entre
les gens voilà
[Musique]